بتاريخ 12/11 اتصلوا علينا جماعه حكوا لنا
انه في تنسيق من الصليب الاحمر وفي ناس
بيمشوا من سويد النصر ماسكين رايات بيضاء
بامكانكم تيجوا معهم وتروحوا باتجاه
الجنوب لانه منطقتنا كانت منطقه محاصره
وبالفعل حملنا حالنا وطلعنا كانت في
دبابتين الدبابه الاولى قطنا منها وقتها
احنا تاكدنا انه ما انه في تنسيق لانه ما
في تنسيق كان رام عن رصاص بكل سهوله يعني
سمعت من وراي بيحكوا امشوا شمال كان في
ناس اللي ورانا جندي ماشر لهم انه يمشوا
شمال كانت خالتي الله يرحمها ماشيه اول
وحده يعني ما كانت لسه وصلها المعلومه
بدها تلف وجهها لما صرنا نن ننادي انه
امشوا شمال امشوا شمال بدها تلف الجه عشان
تفهم ايش ف يعني كانت لسه ما قطه الطريق
الا اجت رصاصه ويعني استشهدت يعني انا
لحتى ههذا اليوم مش مستوعبه احنا كيف
عايشين لانه فع رصاص ما وقف خالتي ه لما
استشهدت كانت ماسكه ايد حفيدها تيم اللي
قبل كم من يوم صار عمري خمس سنوات كان
ماسك الرا البيضا وطفل صغير مش عارف شو
اللي صار لما لما سته اللي هي خالتي وقعت
راح كمل طريق مشي ومشي مع ناس ما بيعرفهم
كان بالاول وضلوا معهم باتجاه الجنوب بعد
ساعه ساعتين توصلنا انه هو فعلا راح في
الجنوب الحمد لله ربنا
سلمه